اكد مسؤول فلسطينيون كبير للجزيره ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه ستشارك يوم غد الاحد في
اجتماع في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه بمشاركه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ومصر والاردن
التي سيمثلها مسؤولون سياسيون وامنيون
رفيع المستوى وقال المسؤول ان هدف
الاجتماع التوصل الى تفاهمات حول فتره
انتقاليه تضمن وقف اسرائيل كافه الاجراءات
الاحاديه من استيطان وهدم واقتحامات لمده
سته اشهر
يتم خلالها التحضير لتهدئه والانتقال الى
مسار اكثر اتساعا وقال ان اسرائيل رفضت
مشاركه اطراف عربيه اخرى ابدت استعدادها
لذلك اشار المسؤول الى ان الاردن ومصر
والولايات المتحده تبذل قصار جهدها لمنع
انفجار الاوضاع خلال شهر رمضان والاعياد
اليهوديه في مارس المقبل